ok 321 servus s kids und herzlich
willkommen zu diesem kleinen login
spätabendlichen setting
ich studiere gerade am see hatte heute
sehr ereignisreichen tag fing alles mit
dem training heute morgen an dann
mittags nachhilfe gegeben
geht ja auch fünf stunden ausprobierten
der verfliegt die zeit aber so krass was
ihr bier das kennt aber zwei drei
stunden verstreichen ihr denkt zwei 15
minuten gewesen jetzt gerade ein
bisschen fußball gespielt da im
hintergrund
das sieht er nicht das noch kleiner
fußballplatz und ja ich bin jetzt gerade
hier unten am see guckt euch das mal an
ist schon sensationell
man sieht auch da hinten die alpen das
sieht man jetzt auf der kamera nicht
because of weitwinkelobjektiv ich bin
auch gab bisschen kaputt wie gesagt bis
gerade im fußball gespielt
was ich aber auch sagen wollte ist ich
habe gerade noch mal den wohlstand im
burger battle gecheckt und wir liegen
mit 1200 woods vorsprung auf platz eins
moment moment leute die konkurrenz hat
gerade nochmal einen aufruf gestartet
haben grad noch mal richtig viel awards
bekommen bis jetzt unbedingt nochmal
dagegenhalten
der link ist nochmal unten in der
beschreibung gerne nochmal voten und
teilen richtig wichtig heute abend 24
uhr ist deadline danach ist es passiert
bis dahin unbedingt gerne nochmal worten
wir haben gerade unterstützung erhalten
von von robles von von george von ben
von cadel dank an euch alle
und ja leute geben noch mal gas wir
gehen übrigens nicht schwimmen wenn sie
zum abkühlen nach dem sport und ja danke
aber für die unterstützung
so wie es aussieht werde ich nicht nur
in denen sie hier springen sondern weil
doch in die isar vielen dank heute ich
werde das jetzt gleich schneiden
hochladen
hier am steg noch ein kleines abendessen
zu mir nehmen und dann zum nächsten
video wieder morgen mit dem gaming video
haut rein macht es gut und genießt den
abend